let's go next to our caller maybe from
here in Boston from the six one seven
area code who's there from six one seven
today how can you hear me well I can
hear you so well yeah who's this oh this
is teri
I'm calling from uh Newton I'm Terry I
just wanted Hey how's everything going
good that's good um I just wanted to
call because um recently there was a
huge spat between I forgot who it was
and some actress in Israel with
Netanyahu and then ah basically caused
by the huge debate in Israel and even
our gal gadot
stepped in to defend the actress and
this was about the comments about how
this blue and white coalition won they'd
have to they have to work with one of
the Arab parties or something I think it
would have to be a coalition partner or
something like that or just wondered
what your take was on the whole you know
idea so you you say you don't remember
who the actresses I certainly have no
idea who it is and I'm not following the
internal sort of matcha Nations of
machinations of Israeli politics so I I
have no idea okay I hear I could look it
up free if you want because I know there
was like a huge is bad about it and
especially now with kind of the nation
state law and the fact that they've
increased the threshold for some of the
last few elections I was just wondering
me like what your thought about that was
like on effects unlike democracy and if
that would be a positive if that would
have like a what kind of these
consequences could be because of the
fact that what you might call it
mariusz are you are you American Israeli
or Israeli or anything like that oh no
no no I'm just just an ordinary American
I just spent all over politics because
I'm a huge fan of the merits party in
Israel so I've been icing following kind
of what's going on in all turn
unfortunate it doesn't look like the
merits party is gonna have a huge aa
shot at winning arm you know winning the
most seats but it looks like they might
if the best-case scenario they might be
able to win like an additional two or
three seats which I'm really happy about
all right very good well I don't know
who the actresses and and I appreciate
the question I'm going to let you go
I just am unsure and I would not be able
to comment